the latest in the Adam Levine Saga yes I
have been following the story very
closely I'm not sure that I've ever
listened to more than one Adam Levine
song I you know he's the guy from Maroon
5 and there was that one song that was
on the radio all the time but I don't I
don't follow this guy very closely and
the long and short of it is he cheated
on his wife apparently and the women
that he allegedly cheated with are
releasing all these DMS and they're
really really lame I bring up the story
not not to scold Adam Levine even for
doing a bad thing though he did do a
very bad thing uh not to even shame the
women for sleeping with a married man
which is very bad they shouldn't have
done that I bring up the story
to just point out how lame this whole
thing is
the textures oh you're so effing
beautiful you're so effing hot oh my
gosh he sounds like like a weird Randy
12 year old boy and it's so this is an
adult with many many millions of dollars
with a family with kids with another kid
on the way he said oh wow you're so
effing hot and if you
've ever been tempted to cheat on your
wife or if you're being tempted right
now to cheat on your wife and you're not
persuaded to avoid doing that because of
God because of morality because of your
vows that you took to your wife at least
consider this
don't cheat on your wife because of how
freaking lame you're going to look oh my
gosh and the thing that is boggling
everybody's mind about this too is that
this guy who okay yeah Rockstar cheats
on his wife wow never heard that story
before it's I think it's the texting of
it all that is what's so weird about it
that this guy is sitting in his room at
night like I'm gonna send naughty little
texts to these random women on Instagram
like bro that is so sad and lame but why
is he doing it
and if the story is true that he did
cheat on his wife
how did that come about
he's doing it because of something that
we all fall into
which is we believe that the online
world isn't real it's not real Twitter's
not real
porn isn't real
the flirty text messages the sort of
lame text messages with these Instagram
models that's not real that's just the
virtual life it's kind of whatever
you're just doing it on your phone in
the in the dark with the blinds closed
it's okay then you're going to go back
out into your real life but it is real
and it it bleeds over into your real
physical life obviously
there there's a huge misconception I
think in our culture because we have a
view of the mind and and virtue and the
soul that suggests that we just need to
blow off steam sometimes you say oh okay
we're I'm just gonna go uh you know well
porn would be a great example actually
I'm just gonna blow off a little steam
I'm gonna look at porn but that's gonna
tame down my passions and so I'm not
gonna go cheat on my wife but it's sort
of the opposite is true it actually just
excites Your Lust it just it just virtue
and vice are just habits and so the more
you do of those things the the more
you're going to do of them and and the
more radically you're going to express
those things
and this is especially true in the
online to real world divide
if you start take gambling for instance
if you start gambling online and you
just play some of these little games and
you say oh it's just fun there's no real
money involved there's no there's no
real Stakes
very often that turns into a full-blown
gambling addiction and people lose real
money even though it seems like it's
just in this virtual world countless
stories of people who download these
stupid little games where it's little
little colored blocks falling and and
then they end up losing lots and lots of
money tens of thousands of dollars
sometimes
because the online world the online life
really does matter right now you got to
go to establishtitles.com Knowles
because I tell you there was a period
when I felt like I wasn't getting no
respect no respect I tell you and then
that all changed thanks to established
titles now I Am Lord Michael Knowles and
you can be a lord or a lady as well you
can get the respect that you deserve all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land in Scotland established titles is a
Project based on an historic Scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as Lance or Lords and Ladies in English
in your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are even
couple packs because you don't want to
be a Lord and then your poor wife
doesn't get to be a lady with your
certificate you could officially add the
prefix Lord or lady to your credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profiles
at plus established titles commits to
preserving The Woodlands not only in
Scotland but around the planet
they've got Partnerships with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our
afforestation efforts and for every
order they receive a tree is planted
established titles told me get this
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
own kingdom and that will be a wonderful
and it will be run with an iron fist
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now if you use code
Knolls you'll get on top of that an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com get your gifts right
now and help support the channel
huge shocking news from the conservative
on The View you know the conservative on
the view of The View
that that group of cackling hens The
View has always a conservative and the
conservative usually is not a
conservative usually the conservative is
a Democrat who pretends to be a
conservative but now the Democrat who
pretends to be a conservative on the
view is saying that she might vote for a
Democrat
is it time for a third party
I think it might be because I think that
the way the parties are structured now
in the primary system we don't elect the
most qualified people we elect the
people who cater the most to the base
which is the minority of both parties
rather than people who are most likely
to want to get things done to work
across the aisle I'll say this I agree
about halfway with Liz Cheney I will
full stop never support an election
denier I still want to work from within
with the Republican party I believe
politics is cyclical and the Donald
Trump moment which has consumed all of
us for so long will eventually come to
an end and I hope to influence the party
from within the Donald Trump party is
not a conservative party it's a populist
nationalist right-wing party that I have
about as much in common with as I do
Bernie Sanders but I want to get back to
something where we are pro-free trade
Pro globalization for legal immigration
into the country securing the Border but
with legal immigration and that's just
not where we are now as far as
supporting Democrats um I'd be open to
on a case-by-case basis I'd have to look
at their policies and that's kind of
where I am
that's where I am look I'm a
conservative I I just look Donald Trump
he's not conservative because he wants
to conserve things you know and he he
believes in concern he's a he's a
right-wing person but I'm not I'm a
conservative and what do I support I
support things like free trade I support
things like Mass migration I support
things she goes down the list
she's she's presenting herself
not as a conservative she's presenting
herself as a Bill Clinton Democrat she's
saying you know like a conservative like
like Bill Clinton he's like no lady that
Donald Trump is much much more
conservative than you are of course I
mean Hillary might be more conservative
than that lady is it's it's all just so
fake and listening to that I I sort of
sympathize with her because maybe in the
90s or sometime in the 2000s that might
have been what this the squishy
conservatives dominated the party and
that might have been what they thought
conservatism was just cut taxes flood
the country with foreigners and did I
mention cutting taxes yeah cut taxes and
have refrigerating globalism that's what
people thought it was
and now in large part thanks to Donald
Trump conservatives are waking up and
saying no actually conservatism is
deeper than just policies of Bill
Clinton okay with more like gay stuff
the policies of Bill Clinton with more
rainbow flags that that actually
conservatism runs a little bit deeper
than that we're kind of going back to a
tradition that is that is much deeper
and much more serious and and so in that
moment
the the squishes in the middle the
Alissa Pharaoh people really all of us
we're looking we're saying what does it
even mean what does it mean to be a
conservative what does it mean to be an
American Patriot that's why it's why
we're all stuck on this question what
the hell am I supposed to think about
Edward Snowden you know the rest of the
show is continuing right now you do not
want to miss it if you are a member
we are going to be getting to fake
headlines today I know it's it's woke
Wednesday we're supposed to get to a
woke commercial or or woke viral video
but I'm on the roads we're gonna swap it
this week okay we're gonna do the fake
headlines you've you've got to see if
you can guess which headline is fake uh
obviously we'll be chatting with you in
the daily wire remember Chad if you're
not already a member all right head on
over click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]